ثلاث سنوات مضت منذ اكتشاف فيروس كورونا
المستجد والى الان الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لم تتوقف عن البحث عن منشا المرض مجله
كشفت عن تسلم البيت الابيض والكونغرس
تقريرا جديدا حول هذه المساله يبين ان
وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه تظن ان الفيروس
تسرب من مختبر صيني يظهر التقرير الجديد
ان جهات الاستخبارات المختلفه توصلت الى
نتائج متباينه حول اصل الوباء ووزاره
الطاقه الان تؤيد مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي
حول احتمال ان يكون الفيروس قد انتشر عبر
حادث مؤسف في مختبر صيني هو مجرد احتمال
فقط ولا اجماع حوله بحسبريد جورنال
المشرعون الامريكيون ولا سيما الجمهوريون
منهم مصرون على الحصول على اجابه شافيه
حول منشا الفيروس وبحسب التقرير فالجهه
الامريكيه تجمع على استبعاد ان يكون كوفيد
19 ثمره لبرنامج صيني للاسلحه البيولوجيه
غير ان الصين غاضبه من مجرد الحديث عن
منشا الفيروس اود ان اقول ان معرفه منشا
كوفيد 19 مساله علميه ولا ينبغي تسييسها
ويجب على الاطراف المعنيه الكف عن اثاره
النقاش حول تسرب المختبر وتشويه سمعه
السجن بالنسبه الى بكين التحقيقات
المشتركه مع منظمه الصحه العالميه انتهت
وهي في احتمال التسرب من المختبر وتذهب
الصين ابعد من ذلك تعتبر ان فيروس كورونا
المستجد ربما نشا خارج اراضيها الا ان
الولايات المتحده تشكك في مصداقيه هذه
النتائج